(whoosh)
- Hello, Believe Nation.
I started the Did You Know series
to try to learn a little bit more
about some of our favorite entrepreneurs,
what makes them tick, what
their upbringing was like.
And so, today we're going to
learn nine surprising facts
about Steve Jobs.
(bell chimes)
Fact number one, he was adopted.
- I dropped out of Reed College
after the first six months,
but then stayed around as a drop-in
for another 18 months or
so before I really quit.
So why'd I drop out?
It started before I was born.
My biological mother was a
young, unwed graduate student,
and she decided to put me up for adoption.
She felt very strongly
that I should be adopted
by college graduates,
so everything was all set
for me to be adopted at birth
by a lawyer and his wife.
Except that when I popped out,
they decided at the last minute
that they really wanted a girl.
So, my parents, who
were on a waiting list,
got a call in the middle
of the night asking,
"We've got an unexpected baby boy.
"Do you want him?"
They said, "Of course."
My biological mother found out later
that my mother had never
graduated from college,
and that my father had never
graduated from high school.
She refused to sign the
final adoption papers.
She only relented a few months later,
when my parents promised
that I would go to college.
This was the start in my life.
When I was looking for
my biological mother,
obviously, y'know,
I was looking for my biological
father at the same time.
And I learned a little bit about him,
and I didn't like what I learned,
and I asked her to not tell him
that we'd ever met, and not
tell him anything about me.
- So, Mona goes to the coffee shop,
meets this guy, Mr.
Jindali, who's running it,
who says, among other
things, when she asks,
how sorry he is, but then he says
that he had had another child,
and Mona said, "What happened to him?"
He said, "Oh, I don't know,
"we'll never hear from him again."
And then he says, "I
wish you could've seen me
"when I was running a bigger restaurant.
"I used to run one of the best restaurants
"in Silicon Valley.
"Everybody used to come there.
"Even Steve Jobs used to eat there."
And Mona's sort of taken aback,
and bites her tongue and doesn't say,
"Steve Jobs is your son."
But she looked shocked, and he says,
"Yeah, he was a great tipper."
- And I was in that
restaurant once or twice,
and I remember meeting the
owner, who was from Syria,
and it was most certainly him.
And I shook his hand,
and he shook my hand,
and that's all.
- And Jobs never spoke to
him, never talked to him,
never got in touch with him,
never wanted to see him.
(bell chimes)
- Fact number two, when
he was 12 years old,
he got a summer job with Hewlett-Packard.
- But I called up Bill Hewlett
when I was 12 years old,
and he lived in Paolo Alto.
His number was still in the phone book.
And he answered the phone himself.
He was like, "Yes?"
I said, "Hi, I'm Steve
Jobs, I'm 12 years old.
"I'm a student in high school,
"and I want to build a frequency counter,
"and I was wondering if you had
"any spare parts I could have."
And he laughed, and he
gave me the spare parts
to build this frequency counter,
and he gave me a job that
summer in Hewlett-Packard,
working on the assembly line,
putting nuts and bolts
together on frequency counters.
He got me a job in the
place that built them,
and I was in heaven.
And I've never found anyone who's said no
or hung up the phone when I called.
I just asked.
And when people ask me, I
try to be as responsive,
to pay that debt of gratitude back.
Most people never pick
up the phone and call,
most people never ask,
and that's what separates, sometimes,
the people that do things
from the people that
just dream about them.
You've got to act,
and you've got to be willing to fail.
You've got to be willing
to crash and burn,
you know, with people on the phone,
with starting a company, with whatever.
If you're afraid of failing,
you won't get very far.
(bell chimes)
- Fact number three, he
was a college dropout.
- But I naively chose a college
that was almost as expensive as Stanford,
and all of my working
class parents' savings
were being spent on my college tuition.
After six months, I couldn't
see the value in it.
I had no idea what I
wanted to do with my life,
and no idea how college
was going to help me figure it out.
And here I was, spending all of the money
my parents had saved their entire life.
So I decided to drop out
and trust that it would all work out okay.
It was pretty scary at the time,
but looking back,
it was one of the best
decisions I ever made.
(crowd laughs)
The minute I dropped out,
I could stop taking the required classes
that didn't interest me,
and begin dropping in on the ones
that looked far more interesting.
It wasn't all romantic.
I didn't have a dorm room,
so I slept on the floor in friends' rooms.
I returned Coke bottles
for the five cent deposits
to buy food with,
and I would walk the
seven miles across town
every Sunday night
to get one good meal a week
at the Hari Krishna Temple.
I loved it.
And much of what I stumbled into
by following my curiosity and intuition
turned out to be priceless later on.
(bell chimes)
- Fact number four,
he experimented with psychedelics
and said it was a profound experience.
- My favorite Steve anecdote was
one day just sitting in my office
and he comes by and he says,
"Hey, Trip, you've never
taken LSD, have you?"
(reporter laughs)
And I said, "No."
And he said, "Yeah, I thought so."
And then he walks away.
So, of course, he and I
understood each other well enough
that he knew that I knew
that what he's basically doing is saying,
"I just came out of a
meeting with somebody,
"and they said that you disagree with me
"in this way about this thing,
"and I'm just thinking to myself,
"that if you had just dropped acid,
"you wouldn't be so damn screwed up."
(both laughing)
Because he really absolutely believed
that LSD had been a very
positive transformation
in how he thought.
- You used to do LSD with Steve Jobs.
Can you take me back
to those college days?
Let's just rewind and go back there.
- Let's see, were we playing Sgt. Pepper?
- What were you playing?
How did this go down?
- It was pretty prosaic.
We were in Portland at Reed College.
You know, freshman college year is
a very poignant time of life where you're
very much trying to figure
out what the world is about
and what you're interested in.
- How'd you guys meet?
- Oh, well at Reed,
Reed was a pastoral environment
and so there was a lot
of hanging out going on,
but Steve and I developed a friendship
when we figured out that we had both read
this amazing book called "Be Here Now,"
which is about psychedelics
and spirituality.
Steve was my best friend
at the time of life
when I was discovering all this
huge current of Eastern literature.
All of a sudden,
psychedelics were being
introduced into the mix
of traditional spirituality,
and that was just very fascinating.
- Do you remember the first time
you guys took psychedelics together?
- No, not really.
We were just kind of walkin' around.
I think we used to go for hikes.
I think we camped out on the beach.
I can't really remember
building a campfire.
I don't remember what
we did when it got dark.
I can tell you that
the times that I was taking
psychedelics with Steve,
we weren't really talking that much.
We were more of in a meditative space.
- Once you were there,
did you and Steve Jobs ever take LSD
or continue to take psychedelics?
- Once Apple started,
Steve was really focused
with all of his energy
on making Apple successful.
And he didn't need psychedelics for that.
(bell chimes)
- Fact number five,
he was fired from Apple.
- As you may know,
I was basically fired
from Apple when I was 30,
and was invited to come
back 12 years later,
so that was difficult when it happened,
but maybe the best thing
that ever happened to me.
There wouldn't be a Pixar
if that hadn't happened.
So, you know, you just move on,
life goes on,
and you learn from it.
- [Interviewer] We're at the end here but,
you were fired from
Apple when you were 30,
asked to come back when you were what, 42?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] Did you
think in that moment
how sweet it is?
- No, I thought at that moment
what a, y'know ...
What a circle of life. (laughs)
Life is just always
mysterious and surprising,
and you never know what's
around the next corner.
(bell chimes)
- Fact number six,
he was one of the youngest people ever
to make the Forbes list of
wealthiest people in the world.
- It's very interesting.
I was worth...
about over a million
dollars when I was 23,
and over 10 million dollars when I was 24,
and over 100 million
dollars when I was 25.
And it wasn't that important,
because I never did it for the money.
I think money is a wonderful thing
cuz it enables you to do things,
it enables you to invest in ideas
that don't have a short-term
payback and things like that,
but especially at that point in my life
it was not the most important thing.
The most important thing was the company,
the people,
the products we were making,
what we were going to enable people to do
with these products.
So I didn't think about it a great deal.
You know, I never sold any stock
and just really believed that the company
would do very well over the long term.
(bell chimes)
- Fact number seven,
he was one of the founders
and was the majority shareholder of Pixar.
- This all started with George Lucas.
He had a problem.
Now, to describe his problem,
let me digress a little bit.
When you make a copy of an
audio cassette tape let's say,
an analog copy of an audio recording,
you get noise artifacts, hiss, right?
We've all experienced that.
Well the same thing happens
when you make an analog
copy or an optical copy
of a piece of film.
If you copy optically one
piece of film to another
you get hiss, if you will,
and in this case the noise
artifacts are visual.
You get a dirty frame.
Well, when George was making
the original Star Wars,
he had to combine many,
many pieces of film together
to make one frame.
Some with the models,
some with the matte paintings,
some with the human characters,
some with the special effects,
and by the time he got through
combining all these pieces of film
to make just one frame of his movie,
it was dirty.
And he, being the genius that he was,
thought, "I wonder if I
could combine them digitally,
"if they could be totally clean."
Because when you make a digital copy
of an analog recording,
it's perfect.
It turns out if you make a digital copy
of a piece of film, it's perfect.
- [Interviewer] Sharper, clearer.
- Sharper, clearer, without
the noise artifacts.
So George hired this guy named Ed Catmull,
who was at the New York
Institute of Technology,
to come out and build a
computer group for him
and to figure out how
to solve this problem,
and they did.
And George was the first
one to ever do this.
And after this problem was solved,
George decided that
he'd solved this problem
he decided he would sell
this computer group.
And I ended up buying them.
I met Ed, and Ed told me his dream
was to make the world's
first computer-animated film,
and I bought into that dream,
both sort of spiritually and financially,
and together we started Pixar in 1986.
(bell chimes)
- Fact number 8,
he was a Zen Buddhist.
- At some point, you guys,
you and Steve Jobs,
you guys decided to go to India, right?
- Yes.
- What was that trip like?
- I didn't have any money.
I had no travel plans,
but Steve had started working at Atari
and he had money.
A couple thousand dollars.
And so he offered to buy my ticket.
I said, "Absolutely, okay, let's go."
We were just traveling around.
Just hippies, traveling around.
We weren't even hippies.
We shaved our heads.
(interviewer laughs)
We were monks.
We were monk wannabes.
(bell chimes)
- Fact number nine,
him and his friend Steve Wozniak
created illegal blue boxes
which they used to call the Vatican
and wake up the Pope.
- So we built these little boxes
to do blue boxing, as it was called.
And we put a little note
in the bottom of 'em,
our logo was "he's got the
whole world in his hands."
(laughs)
And they worked,
we built the best blue box in the world.
It was all digital, no adjustments,
and so you could go up to a pay phone,
and you could take a
trunk over to White Plains
and then take a satellite over to Europe
and then go to Turkey, take
a cable back to Atlanta,
and you could go around the world.
You could go around the
world five or six times
cuz we learned all the codes
for how to get on the
satellites and stuff.
And then you could call
the payphone next door,
and so you could shout in the phone
and after about a minute it
would come out the other phone.
It was miraculous.
And you might ask,
"Well what's so interesting about that?"
What's so interesting
is that we were young,
and what we learned was
that we could build something ourselves
that could control
billions of dollars worth of
infrastructure in the world.
That was what we learned,
was that us, too,
y'know, we didn't know much,
we could build a little thing
that could control a giant thing.
And that was an incredible lesson.
I don't think there would have
ever been an Apple Computer
had there not been blue boxing.
- [Interviewer] Woz said
you called the Pope.
- Yeah, we did call the Pope.
He pretended to be Henry Kissinger.
Yeah, we got the number of the Vatican,
and we called the Pope,
and they started waking people
up in the hierarchy, y'know,
Cardinals and this and that,
and they actually sent
someone to wake up the Pope,
when finally we just burst out laughing
and they realized that we
weren't Henry Kissinger,
and so we never got to talk to the Pope,
but it was very funny.
- So that's what we got,
those are the nine surprising
facts about Steve Jobs.
I hope you enjoyed this video,
I'd love to know what did you think,
what fact was the most interesting
or resonated the most with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you,
hope you continue to believe in yourself,
and whatever you one word is,
much love.
See you soon.
(whoosh)